Some movie scenes are so hilarious, exciting,
or romantic that we can go back to watch them
again and again and never get tired of them.
Then there are the other ones: the unsettling
moments and creepy scenes that stick with
us even if we only watched them once.
Here are just a few of the uncomfortable movie
scenes that we'll never, ever watch again.
In The Nice Guys, Holland March is the worst
detective in Los Angeles, maybe even the world.
"It's just Fred's never been gone this long
before."
"How long has he been missing?"
"Since the funeral."
Played by a hilarious Ryan Gosling, March
is a bumbling alcoholic who's hired to find
a missing adult film star.
His quest is filled with all sorts of injuries,
both to his pride and his well-being, but
the most painful moment comes when he accidentally
slits his wrist.
At one point, March tries the old P.I. trick
of just wrapping up his hand, punching through
a small pane of glass, and reaching inside
to unlock the door.
But March is no action hero.
Needless to say, he immediately regrets it.
Granted, the scene is played for laughs, and
Gosling does an amazing job selling the comedy...
"A lot of blood…
That's a…
That’s a lot of blood."
… but, seeing (and hearing) all that blood
leaves us feeling queasy, and that definitely
isn't nice, guys.
With a title like Creep, it should come as
no surprise that this horror flick is one
uncomfortable experience.
The film follows an unlucky cameraman named
Aaron who's hired to make a video for a weirdo
named Josef, who claims he's dying of cancer
and wants to make a film for his unborn child.
But this seemingly sweet idea gets freakier
and freakier as Josef abandons Aaron in the
woods, tells him a disturbing tale about his
marriage, and performs a song-and-dance number
while wearing a wolf mask.
"At the end of the day, it’s gonna be normal,
so…"
"Oh, okay."
"Trust me, that’s not gonna be anything
weird at all."
But all that comes after Josef’s first bit
of creepiness.
Early in the film, he tells Aaron to follow
him into the bathroom for "tubby time."
When Josef was a little kid, he would take
baths with his dad.
Since he won't be around to share this with
his son, Josef wants to recreate that experience
on film.
And yeah, watching from Aaron’s perspective
as Josef strips down and starts playing with
an imaginary baby in the bathtub is about
as awkward and unsettling as it sounds.
Then, it gets weirder.
One moment, Josef is playing with his imaginary
kid, and the next, he sinks into a depression,
starts talking about s, and slides under
water like he plans to drown .
When Aaron leans over the tub to check on
Josef and the madman comes screaming at the
camera, it's quite the jump scare and perfectly
sets the mood for all the creepiness to come.
Steve Carell is no stranger to cringe-worthy
moments…
"Been a lot of fun talk about prison today,
but I am here to scare you straight!
I AM HERE TO SCARE YOU STRAAAAIGHT!"
... but after leaving The Office, he wound
up in more awkward situations in Foxcatcher.
This film, based on a tragic true story, finds
Carell playing John du Pont, an eccentric
millionaire with a fondness for firearms,
cocaine, and combat sports.
Even though he's incredibly rich, du Pont
is still desperate to win the approval of
his mother, a cold woman more fond of her
prize-winning horses than her own son.
Searching for just a tiny bit of praise, du
Pont starts a wrestling team in hopes of winning
some Olympic gold.
Even though he's just a novice when it comes
to the sport, he takes control of the class
from coach Dave Schultz, played by Mark Ruffalo,
and starts giving an inspirational speech
to the athletes about representing America
and becoming "winners in life."
Things get especially cringey when he calls
one of the wrestlers onto the mat and demonstrates
some incredibly basic techniques in an attempt
to impress his mom.
Eventually, du Pont winds up on the ground
with a guy on his back, and that's when his
mom leaves with a disapproving scowl.
The look on du Pont's face is heartbreaking,
and even though he's a manipulative psycho,
watching this man humiliate himself will make
you wrestle with some complicated feelings.
"I don’t like the sport of wrestling, as
you know.
It’s a low sport."
Even by the standards of Quentin Tarantino,
The Hateful Eight is full of mean, disgusting
moments that will make you squirm in your
seat.
In fact, it might have the single grossest
scene that Tarantino has ever put to film:
the poisoned coffee sequence.
The Hateful Eight finds a bunch of killers
trapped inside a cabin as a blizzard rages
outside.
Among these shootists and scoundrels, we've
got John Ruth, a bounty hunter handcuffed
to notorious murderer Daisy Domergue.
Ruth knows that Daisy has an inside man in
the cabin who wants to kill him and set his
outlaw boss free, but Ruth never suspects
that mysterious mole would go so far as to
poison his coffee.
After takes a swig from his mug, he immediately
starts vomiting what we can only call… extra
chunky blood.
"Really?
Nobody got a problem with this?"
That kicks off a chain reaction in the film,
and maybe even the audience, and by the end
of it, Ruth is dead, and we’re looking sideways
at Starbucks for the rest of our lives.
"You got anything in here besides coffee that
can help warm us up?"
"The bar is open!
Follow moi."
Annihilation isn't what you'd call a feel-good
flick.
Directed by Alex Garland, this sci-fi movie
deals with some heavy themes like regret,
infidelity, and depression.
On top of all that, you've got the Shimmer,
an alien electromagnetic field that mixes
and matches the DNA of any living creature
that steps inside its translucent walls.
As a result, we're treated to a nightmare
world where deformed animals scream like human
beings, alligator-sharks grow to enormous
size, and Tessa Thompson turns into a tree.
But the most horrific image inside the Shimmer
comes when our heroes discover an old video
camera that reveals the fate of an earlier
expedition.
When they play the footage, we see a wild-eyed
soldier played by Oscar Isaac performing some
amateur surgery on one of his comrades.
That’s bad enough by itself, but then we
see why: thanks to the Shimmer's gene-splicing
abilities, this guy's intestines have come
to life, and they're oozing around like some
giant worm.
It's a scene that starts off sadistic before
taking a turn into Lovecraft territory, and
no matter how hard you try, you'll never be
able to annihilate this moment from your memory.
The King of Comedy was the fourth collaboration
between Robert De Niro and Martin Scorsese,
and while it's not as well known as Taxi Driver
or Raging Bull, it's definitely the most awkward
movie they've ever made.
A black comedy about the dark side of show
business, the film finds De Niro as Rupert
Pupkin, a wannabe comedian who idolizes late
night talk show host Jerry Langford, played
by Jerry Lewis.
Rupert thinks if he could just get on Jerry's
show and perform his set, then he could make
it into the big time.
However, Rupert is a delusional creep who
fantasizes about being Jerry's best friend.
Eventually, the fantasy spills over into reality
when Rupert starts stalking Jerry, and even
shows up at Jerry's mansion, completely uninvited.
Making things worse, Rupert has brought along
a date, who has no idea that her psycho boyfriend
isn't really friends with the talk show host.
"Oh, no, no, we just thought we’d drop in
uninvited for the weekend."
Slowly but surely, Rupert's date realizes
they're not supposed to be in this man's house,
and we can totally feel this poor woman's
embarrassment, but Rupert just keeps on pretending
that he's Jerry's best friend.
The whole scene is shudderingly awkward, and
it feels so genuinely raw and confrontational
because the actors were improvising all their
lines.
Darren Aronofsky‘s Requiem For a Dream might
be the most traumatic film of all time, and
probably the greatest anti-drug PSA ever made.
Every moment with Ellen Burstyn as Sarah Goldfarb
is just heartbreaking, all building up to
the infamous climax where our four main characters
experience what it must be like to visit hell.
If we had to pick one element of the film
that absolutely forces viewers to look away
in disgust, though, it could be any scene
involving Jared Leto's arm.
"What’s the problem?"
"It’s my arm!
My arm is killing me!"
"Let’s have a look at it."
Leto plays Harry Goldfarb, a heroin addict
whose intravenous drug use causes a vein in
one of his arms to become horribly infected.
In one of the saddest moments of the film,
the arm grows so disgusting that it’s amputated
during an operation, but before that awful
moment, we witness a jittery Harry prepare
to shoot up by sticking the needle in his
swollen, black arm.
The injection site is oozing with dark liquid,
but Harry jabs that needle into the vein anyway,
causing moviegoers everywhere to say no to
drugs.
The Square is an award-winning satire of the
contemporary art world, but it also contains
an infamously show-stopping sequence: the
Monkey Man scene.
It happens at a prestigious dinner party,
where a muscle-bound artist storms into a
room full of wealthy patrons.
This guy is hunched over, with stilts attached
to his arms, and he's howling like an ape.
He's a performance artist pretending to be
a chimpanzee, and at first, it seems like
fun and games.
He waddles around the room, grunts, and amuses
the patrons with his eerily accurate chimp
impression.
But just like real chimps, the artist gets
ultra-aggressive incredibly fast, stalking
around the room and harassing guests.
The terrified patrons keep perfectly quiet
and still, but things finally go way too far
when he leaps on a table and assaults a female
patron, prompting everyone in the room to
beat him to a pulp.
This insane performance goes on for around
12 minutes, and perhaps it feels so real because
Notary actually picked on extras he sensed
were nervous whenever he walked by.
Don’t worry too much, though: the woman
he attacked was played by a stunt person who
was aware of and ready for the scene.
The final product is unbearably tense and
amazingly uncomfortable, and just like the
horror-struck patrons, we don't want to revisit
this terrifying experience again.
Tusk is not a great movie.
It bombed at the box office, it offended critics,
and it features one of Johnny Depp's worst
performances, which is saying something.
There are, however, a couple of killer scenes,
and perhaps the most horrifically uncomfortable
moment comes when podcaster Wallace Bryton,
played by Justin Long, realizes he's missing
a pretty important body part.
After meeting an eccentric adventurer called
Howard Howe while looking for a good story
for his show, Wallace drinks some spiked tea,
and wakes up later in a wheelchair, heavily
anesthetized and minus a leg.
Still under the effects of Howard's spiked
tea, Wallace is freaks out when he sees his
stitched-up stump, and Howard explains that
a doctor had to amputate the limb after Wallace
was bitten by a brown recluse.
But as tears well up in Wallace's eyes, Howard
is trying to hold back laughter.
After all, he's the one who cut the leg off
as part of a twisted experiment.
Tusk is a little tough to watch for a lot
of reasons, but in this case, it’s on purpose.
From its 2001: A Space Odyssey-style opening
to its fiery finale, everything about 2013’s
Under the Skin is eerie.
Even though this film has dudes getting sucked
out of their skin, however, the most unsettling
moment has got to be that awful beach scene.
Scarlett Johansson plays an extraterrestrial
being who lures men to their deaths, usually
by driving around in a van, picking up guys
and taking them back to her apartment, where
they meet a fate worse than death.
In this particular scene, though, Johansson
is hunting for prey at a Scottish beach, where
she witnesses a woman getting pulled out into
the sea.
She dispassionately watches the woman disappear
into the waves, and she doesn't move to help
when the woman's lover drowns trying to save
her.
In fact, she only reacts after a would-be
hero tries in vain to save the couple and
is washed ashore unconscious.
She drags the man to her van, intent on killing
him, and completely ignores the drowned couple’s
abandoned baby, crying in terror on the beach.
Johansson’s character never feels more inhuman
and predatory than she does here, and her
cruel indifference leaves a sick, cold feeling
in our stomachs.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.